Kate Hudson is getting ready to welcome
her baby girl
the actress took to Instagram on
Thursday to show off her growing baby
bump
that's a 39 year old rocking an orange
bikini and a floor-length robe for a
mama Mir selfie but this isn't the first
time the Mother's Day star who has two
sons from previous relationships has
given fans a peek at her first pregnancy
with boyfriend Danny Fujikawa since
announcing that she's expecting back in
April
kate has documented many of the sweet
moments along the way including her
gender reveal and an Italian baby moon
in April et caught up with Kate's best
friend and Danny step sister Erin Foster
who couldn't help but gush over the baby
news it's such a beautiful thing
our stepbrother and Kate getting
together after 20 years of friendship
has been such a beautiful thing and then
they were hoping so badly they're gonna
have a girl and then when they found out
they're happy and she did not know until
the balloons popped in pink came out and
it was just it was just too much it was
just it was amazing
[Music]
[Applause]